io vi devo spiegare una cosa ragazzi ci
sono dei videogiochi che la gente fa c'è
sapevo di programmatori che fanno certi
videogiochi che non hanno troppo senso
ma a volte si sfiori tipo happy with è
una merda però è strano eh vabbè tanto
ormai siamo abituati però ci sono leggi
di merda ma polo di merda siamo summa di
aids ed è un gioco dove devi lanciare
una merda dal balcone o dal terrazzo
dove cazzo siamo e farla cadere sulla
gente
bene basta come come come la lanciò la
merda così vogliono le persone che
escono giochi tipo battlefield tipo gta
quando c'è questa roba
perché qual è il problema cosa sta
succedendo
lui è contentissimo di questa cosa vero
che c'hai anche i peli sul petto e
fatevi di partire che il sono ansioso di
ritirare la mia merda bene in base al
punteggio che fai puoi anche comprare
delle cose tipo l'hamburger che ti fa
fare la pupù in ogni anno fa cazzo
sempre più solida bella io devo devo
pagare intendo con questa cosa qua
veramente non la vedi che per terra e la
peste che questo è il gioco della merda
che l'arte che parte dal balcone anche
detto la rilancio delle iter non credo
che domani
possa inventare altre armi di
distruzioni di massa basta lanciare le
merde dal balcone vedi che roba comunque
molto etero questa corsa etero tanto
quanto la maglietta ma posso tipo
beccare il piccione quello che passa
questo qui l'ho preso
ma come un piccione merda volante
ragazzi perfetto le macchine le posso
pre ad affari che devo proverebbe che
alle macchine vedere cosa succede o
provare tutto in questo gioco fantastico
ma sbanda ma cosa ha sbandato la marcia
ma perché grave incidente in autostrada
una macchina sbanda perché una merda che
va beh quando siete [ __ ]
quanti problemi ecco lo sapevo
ogni giorno io sono orgoglioso di fare
questo lavoro da youtuber perché mi dà
soddisfazione non è per la passione i
soldi ma che cazzo se ne per questo è
quello che vale il lavoro da youtuber
questo è per questo che io mi alzo la
mattina con che ragazzi facciamo
l'aggiornamento visto che questo gioco è
andato a gonfie vele e non sto
scherzando
ora questo è stato scaricatissimo come
gioco ve lo giuro hanno fatto il seguito
e l'hanno venduto su steam cioè nel
senso è a pagamento su steam
andiamo a vedere che il kazan fatto ad
ii x2 hanno fatto ma di hayes 2 dove la
merda va in giro costa ben 3 euro grazie
steam quello che voglio da questo sito è
quello che mi aspetto nel 2016 dove
l'era del videogioco si sviluppa a
livelli mai visti prima grazie
evoluzione dell'essere umano ci siamo
ragazzi l'ho appena installato e
proviamo subito a vedere che orgasmo
videoludico non è questa roba ci andiamo
subito a vedere bene la partenza non è
niente male
signore e signori state per assistere al
videogioco della vita e quindi tenetevi
pronti potreste avere della pelle d'oca
è quindi pensiamo
partiamo subito col primo livello
ragazzi dichiarano xvi l'anno sviluppato
che la metà basta regali spetta prima
hanno fatto le animazioni degli oggetti
che prendi o addirittura non posso devo
prima cagare e poi mangio le cose bank
ag chiamo
cosa faccio la lanciò a caso a caso la
mia posso per 90 secondi che non sono 90
secondi mai nella vita posso dei tu sei
un figo i 3 euro spesi meglio della mia
vita e non ho alcun dubbio tape ci sono
delle cose da trovare tipo carta
igienica e cazzo e la carta igienica
se io trovo per caso è successo ho
trovato la carta igienica ragazzi uno su
tre che lo mancata pure va bene
collector fm quante ce ne sono ancora
due vele trovo che ne so io che può
essere l'altra capita ma non è che è di
nuovo qua con quale fisica mi è tornata
la merda indietro scusate mi vedete la
carta igienica in giro che io non vedo
per cortesia filaccia iniettato un
ombrello l'ombrello di merda perfetto
l'acqua si trova l'altra carta igienica
ragazza non ha idea di dove sia
dov'era nascosta ma mica in così
sconosciuto livello found secret che che
secret che è successo
il camion della merda fantastico questo
danno un sacco di punti sicuro effetto
potrete spostare studente devo trovare è
se riesco a trovare l'altra carta
igienica per finire gli l'obiettivo sono
a posto il problema che non la trovo la
non ascolta benissimo verrà messa a sti
maledetti stronzi ecco ecco la trovata
del paper fumetto grazie ma va ragazzi
credo sia un gioco abbastanza
competitivo per il fatto che comunque
non ho trovato l'ultimo un pezzo di
carta igienica deva fare gli altri
livelli che è meglio comunque per adesso
si classifica come gioco dell'anno per
me va bene qua già la vedo la
la carta igienica due no viste mila per
trovarne uno e sommesso una vita qua già
ne vedo due gruppi
alla fine se riusciamo a fare una roba
seria stavolta no perché il resto non
era serio quanto l'anno migliorato sto
gioco guarda hanno fatto gli 6 guai
bellissimo e tipo morto ma ma questo
nuovo meno che non ci fosse un dj fermi
chamartin garics c'è da capire e
complimenti per il sombrero frate scusa
per lo sgambetto tu non tentare
rimorchiare e una giornata abbastanza di
merda per questo faccio io faccio io
dj boop in consolle arrivare più cioè
singer
ma come contento di partecipare a questa
a questo rave party difetti capire come
faccia raggiungere c'è una piscina ma mi
prendete per il culo e non lo sapevo che
sa che gioia vedersi una merda che
galleggia così direi di andare su quelli
che fanno le flessioni
vabbè mi che cazzo sei rocky balboa brio
workout
questo invece l'asta fancazzo però c'è
anche un [ __ ] trampolino quanto figo
suo gioco quanto li vale questi tre euro
gliene davo 50 se lo sapevo
togliti e faccio io non posso perché la
merda non possa andare sul trampolino
questo razzismo
ho trovato l'altra carta igienica e juan
perfetta la brianza e secondariamente
anche dall'altra anche se dubito ma cosa
ci faccio forse
perfetto la merda bagnino così se
qualcuno affoga in realtà è meglio che
affoghino tra queste ce l'abbiamo se
riuscisse a prendere l'ultimo pezzo di
merda che non è un insulto ma a evacua
sotto perfetto perfetto questo video
giocare secondo fa vj e stato difficile
perché giochi del genere richiedono
appunto allenamento vero ce l'ho fatta
madonna che figo
certo che sono proprio euro ben spesi
adesso di provocare se piccola la
montagna russa quanto micro porca
[ __ ] bene pup maghetto alla madonna
canta tragedia set che quello che cos'è
frate credo che sia bellicose di tocco
venne dirty job lavoro sporco vedere se
riesco a fermare la giostra
ecco ecco ecco la prefetto chiede lei
incastrata su un unicorno mongolo
perfetto è stato sono gli unicorni più
belli che abbia mai visto c'è un bambino
perche perche questa qualcosa appena
visto ma devo fare una combo per 20 cosa
cazzo fai a fare una combo per vento di
de carlo uccello revenge doppio voglio
provare vedere se riesco a raggiungere
la la cosa lì perché c'è una merda
gigante là sopra a vela sa perda più
veloce perfetto mi porti su quanto non
ha senso sta cosa va bè ragazzi dire che
poco basta soltanto capire belle tette
zio detto che youtube nella censura sta
cosa volevo soltanto capire fino a che
punto ci si può spingere uno
sviluppatore di un videogioco nel fare
un videogioco e soprattutto fino a che
punto si può spingere 1 youtuber nel
fare determinati gameplay ragazzuoli
spero che mi sia piaciuto spero che
abbiate capito l'importanza del
dell'essenza videoludica moderna vedrai
che sony spero che vi sia piaciuto che è
quanto appare è stato alquanto profondo
e quindi credo sia piaciuto a tutti non
vedo perché non debba piacere un video
del genere
se volete mi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook che come visto trascrizione
sensor city siete i cibi diavolo fosse
un video da ragazzi
io